- They told me I was a lineman, not a frontman.
- This is our big chance!
Every single person from the media showed up.
- I have a major announcement.
It's the Eagles!
[Audience cheering]
The football team.
- [Audience:] Aww.
- Jingle bells, jingle bells...
[Snickering]
♪♪♪ Jingle all the way. ♪♪♪
[Cheering]
- Oh, my God, they're better than the Chiefs!
- Eaglemania swept the nation.
And who managed that s--t but me, Nicky Sirianni?
- I heard you're looking for a little of that Nashville sound.
- So, crikey, the head 'ranger wanted to add some joeys.
- He means Sirianni added some folks.
- Things did get a little weird when the band entered their Batman era.
- ♪♪♪ Dark Knight,
Bruce Wayne. ♪♪♪
- They were the Eagles, but then they added bats.
It was too many animals.
- You've changed, Jason. I'm supposed to be the hot brother.
- ♪♪♪ You're a mean one, Mr. Snyder. ♪♪♪
[Cheering]
- We got upstaged by the f--king Commanders.
- ♪♪♪ Daboll, Daboll, Daboll.
The refs threw the game our way. ♪♪♪
- Maybe I could play lead?
- Quiet, Tony Pollard!
Zeke's the star.
- We had to get back to what got us there in the first place.
- No rules, just right.
- This one goes out to all the haters.
♪♪♪ We wish you a Merry Christmas! ♪♪♪